- On Sunday night, Taylor Swift
debuted her music video for Delicate
at the iHeartRadio Music Awards.
I would have preferred a music video
for Dancing With Our Hands Tied,
but Delicate will have to do.
(wooshing)
(squeaking)
(light music)
Because Taylor Swift is Taylor Swift,
and the internet is the internet,
it didn't take long before
fans started finding
or maybe making up Easter eggs.
A few eagle eyed viewers
spotted a reference hidden
in the subway sequence.
It said track five on the pillar.
The song is the fifth track on Reputation.
A lot of fans pointed out
the clear reference to
Singing in the Rain, while
others called out the music video
for potentially ripping
off this perfume ad.
And literally just one person
has pointed out the similarities to the
1960 Italian Film L'Avventura.
But perhaps the most obvious references
are to her British boyfriend Joe Allen.
For example, the song has lyrics like,
"Oh damn, never seen that blue color."
And you guessed it, Joe has blue eyes.
Queen of metaphors.
Other references area
little bit more subtle.
Like the one seen here.
Way in the background,
you can see a sign for Joe's Deli.
And Twitter user, taylors_cookies,
cute Twitter name TBH,
points out that Swift spells out J-O-E
while she dances.
Though if you play out the video,
there are a few other letters
that taylors_cookies left out,
so unless Taylor was trying to right out
L-J-O-T-E, this theory
might just be a coincidence.
Sorry taylors_cookies.
Other connections are a
little bit harder to deny.
The Washington Post
speculates that Delicate
is the answer to the question
where has Taylor been.
Hence, why she becomes invisible
at the start of the video.
On the red carpet, someone slipped her
a glittery note which
the lyrics tell us read,
"Dive bar on the east side.
"Where you at?"
Twitter use, Reagan Dorton,
and a number of other fans speculate that
Joe is the one who hands her the note.
And I speculate that Taylor Swift
has never been to a dive bar.
After Taylor reads the
note, poof, she's invisible.
She's only seen at the end of the video
by people we guess are her friends.
It's not a far stretch to imagine that
Taylor's message in this video is that
she wants to retreat from the public eye
and enjoy her relationships in secret.
Or maybe she just really loves that movie
Hollow Man starring Kevin Bacon.
Who's to say?
I'm sure just starting
to scratch the surface
of all the little hidden details
that are hidden in the video.
But it just goes to show you that
whenever Taylor Swift
posts anything anywhere,
the entire world is watching.
Some,
more intently than others.
(mellow happy music)
(wooshing)
(squeaking)